[Music]
today
what's up everybody you've been
messaging the all morning about the last
season three finale season four stuff so
let's break it down we got a whole bunch
of details about the finale the
beginning of season four so I'll explain
that there's a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video if you're new to the
channel too just because everybody
checks in for finale stuff giveaway
winners are usually announced at the end
of videos in everybody let me know if
you think the audio is a little bit
better I changed the way I do my audio
from behind the scenes so it should
sound better biggest thing first though
the producers confirmed a big detail
about the finale that we all thought
like theory has been confirmed and I'll
back it up with some of the promo images
they released so their comment reads
there will be an ultimate showdown with
savitur in the finale but their battle
isn't probably quite what you're
expecting just because Sava tar is a
version of bury doesn't mean it's going
to play out exactly as people would
expect and they say just make of that
what you will so I talked about this
during my arrow Deathstroke trailer
video both the flash and arrow this
season have been about the heroes
crossing the line in the consequences of
that ferry goes back in time creates
flashpoint because he just can't deal
with the death of his mother and his
father so the big consequence of that is
Savitt our prometheus is the consequence
of Oliver's bloodlust in his actions for
the past five years the ending the
producers are teasing is that Barry is
not going to defeats avatar the same way
he defeated zoom so we fought him and he
got the time race to come take him away
he became the black flash the servant of
the Speed Force to pay for all his
speedsters crimes messing with the
natural order of things and mostly I
think that has to do with the time
remnants he created many of them killed
them all now Barry has gone and done the
same thing
so sabot R is the consequence the lesson
they're trying to teach him which is
probably why you haven't seen them send
the black flash to take him away because
Barry has this pattern of behavior for
something bad happening him not liking
it and just going back in time to change
the natural order of things
it affects everyone's lives but Barry
does it because it's going to make him
feel better like the least heroic thing
that you could possibly do what did that
lead to the big sabotage speech about
how he was this
usable person that a future version of
bury this 2024 version created to stop
another version of Savitt are before he
realized what the truth was more
examples of buried doing whatever he
wants no matter how it affects the
people around him
sabotage feels like he doesn't matter
that's why he wants to become a god so
it seems like the solution is simple you
just makes avatar feel like he matters
his existence is relevant it sounds
really simple when you think about it
that way but the producers are just
teasing that the actual solution like
when you think about it is really simple
it's just that all this big crazy epic
finale action set piece stuff is going
to be happening where it seems like
based on pictures like this that there's
some sort of worldwide catastrophe that
they both caused because looking at this
image here savat r has already killed
iris West
he doesn't need baryon anymore he says
his ascension is at hand
why is he in STAR Labs looking like he's
there against his will then you go to
this image here this looks like it
happens earlier with him and killer
frost just enjoying the fruits of their
victory or perceived victory so it just
sounds like sabotage does not get the
victory that he thinks he's going to get
when he kills iris West and Barry seems
broken we've talked about it before what
does it mean to become a god of speed is
he going to become a Speed Force
wormhole alien nothing he has done has
demonstrated that he actually knows
what's going to happen there's a whole
bunch of new killer broster standing
next to Cisco in the woods
they look like they're watching this
scene here wheres avatars trying to
enter the Speed Force with the look on
her face in that promo it's just like oh
my god like she almost looks like she's
ready to cry like she has no idea what's
going on but the funny thing about that
is that we've heard from other people
that he just casts everyone away once
he's done with them so it sounds like he
intends to double-cross killer frost as
well who cares about her I only care
about me that's the whole theme of the
season Barry only cares about himself
he's going to do whatever it takes to
make himself feel better now we have a
future version of him it's named sabot R
that's doing the exact same thing so
that looks like it creates some of the
seed inside her to join team flash or at
least not be quite so evil because Cisco
has both of his hands so
clearly they've already changed time
enough so that Cisco doesn't get his
Terminator hands now just because this
map is going nuts doesn't mean that
everything's going nuts around the world
savat ours already started changing time
so much that you think about the Jay
Garrick coffee cup explainer that we got
at the beginning of the season there you
keep going back in time trying to change
things you start cracking time in a way
that you can't put back together you
like you put the piece back in here but
there still cracks along the edges so
Barry is destroying time Salvatore is
only making it worse so it just sounds
like the big epic disaster of the finale
is going to have something to do with
them screwing with the Speed Force both
Savitt R and Barry but they did confirm
for season four so like transitioning to
season four stuff they've released the
synopsis so I'll read that it's very
cryptic but it does confirm a few things
but they've already said that the main
villain won't be a speedster but they
named Avvo the thinker we have a lot of
the Rogues they're just so many people
they already have on the flash that they
could surface but there's always a new
character they bring in some new actors
something really exciting here's the
official season 4 synopsis so a lot of
this sounds familiar so I'm just going
to like brush over to the new stuff
fastest man alive but then it says this
is a new step but when Barry used his
extraordinary abilities to travel back
in time and save his mother's life he
inadvertently created an alternate
timeline known as flashpoint a
phenomenon that gave birth to the
villainous Speed God known as Sava tar
and changed the lives of Caitlin snow
and Wally West forever with the help of
his adoptive father Joe West his
lifelong best friend and love interest
iris West
and his friends at STAR Labs Cisco Ramon
Julianne Albert entered 19 novelist HR
wells Barry continues to protect the
people of central city from the
metahumans that threaten it so two big
things in there that they low-key tease
for season 4 1 Julian is coming back so
if you like tom felton I feel like
they'll do his character some more
justice he hasn't gotten a lot of
backstory he got like a lot around
episode 9 we got a little bit of a
prequel for him we learned about his
family but there's just so much that we
don't know about him and HR is coming
back it implies that he's not going to
die in the finale if they directly
name-drop him
the season four synopsis so there's a
bunch of stuff they don't reveal like
Tracy brand isn't mentioned anywhere in
that but that doesn't mean that she's
going to die or she's going to be coming
on it just means that they're presenting
the simplest version of the synopsis as
possible but even though we know that
berry is going to come back somebody is
still supposed to die in the finale
there's a big funeral scene we see
coming up does that mean that the time
remnant ends up dying I don't think that
that's the case because they're supposed
to make him feel like he matters bring
him into the fold somehow but obviously
we're not going to have two versions of
bury next season so something's going to
have to happen in some big disaster and
it'll have something to do with bury
going away into the speedforce
still the biggest theory but obviously
something would have to bring him back
at the beginning of the season so there
are almost more questions than there are
answers even though this confirms a
bunch of big details but let me know
what you think about the season 4
synopsis Julianne and H are coming back
what it says about the finale in whose
body you think is going to get dropped
in the finale what's going to happen
next is there's new Game of Thrones
there's a bunch of new Marvel stuff that
drop they'll try to get that out as fast
as possible or they'll probably new
trailer on Monday and then I'll explain
a little bit next week about how my
bonus video scheduled for a flash stuff
is going to work during the off season
there'll be a couple flash videos per
week but it'll just depend on what
things that you guys want to talk about
specifically in how much comic book
stuff you want to talk about
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Michael Habib please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details while
you wait for everything you can click
here for that arrow Deathstroke trailer
and you can click here for brand-new
Wonder Woman thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you